all right for today's classic interview
we're going back to my January no
October of 2014 interview with adult
film director Dave pounder not his real
name as you can probably imagine we
actually had a really interesting
conversation about these issues that can
come up
not only for adults film performers but
for people in other stigmatized
industries as well when they try to get
jobs in the future we talked about
indecency we talked about censorship and
so many interesting issues so I don't
know why the day of Donald Trump's
inauguration made me want to revisit an
interview with a porn director called
Dave pounder you make the connection I'm
not really sure why but that is today's
classic interview let's take a look I'm
joined today by Dave pounder who is a
retired adult film producer director
performer also author of the book
obscene thoughts a pornographers
perspective on sex love and dating Dave
it's great to have you you know one
thing I want to start with is we have a
couple of these stories one from 2011
where a Los Angeles traffic officer was
fired for having appeared in a porn film
in 2013 there was this middle school
science teacher Staci haleyss who was
fired after appearing in a porn film
they had appeared in legal employment
they had not done anything that was
against the law yet they were fired
let's start there was this something
that people in the industry think of
when they decide to participate in adult
films you know most people that come
into the business are pretty young
particularly the girls are probably 18
to 23 generally speaking and I think
most of them are pretty naive in life at
that time so they don't really think
about the long-term implications of the
decisions that they make more generally
not so much just an employment that
maybe inmate selection and other things
that they do in life now granted you
know I was fully aware of that there
would be sort of social consequences if
you will for being involved you know if
them there's this but I welcomed those
challenges you know part of my decision
to get into the adult film industry was
to take someone like myself it has a
perfectly you know legitimate background
and sense that I'm well educated I have
no car
background not involved with drugs etc
to sort of challenge that social stigma
and say you know there isn't anything
wrong with sexuality it's perfectly
natural you know and people shouldn't be
discriminated against merely because in
one life not just the adult film
industry but maybe they went to a
swingers club with their partner or
maybe they were just a dancer you know
or maybe they they were a nude model for
a painting class um you know it really
depends what people's definition of you
know pornography is you know it's a very
subjective decision if you and your wife
make a video and you don't distribute it
are you a pornographer buys by some
standards you are by other standards
you're not what if you make a video and
you put it up on the web on a server but
it never gets downloaded is the fact
that you made it available for download
enough to you know call you a
pornographer and then you know have you
dismissed from a job well there's those
specifics with regard to what we could
all agree a kind of falls under that
umbrella but then there's even more gray
area I mean what if someone were to be
an actor in an r-rated movie that was
particularly explicit right it pushed
the boundaries of what would be allowed
in terms of sexual content in an r-rated
movie or maybe it was nc-17 but in
another country it was the equivalent of
r-rated we're opening up this and I hate
to call slippery slopes when I don't
think they exist but we really are
opening up a slippery slope here aren't
we
oh absolutely in that in to add to your
list of analogies there is you think
about somebody who has a non-sexual role
in an adult film right where did you go
role even or yeah yeah so you're behind
the scenes you're a cameraman or you
know you rented out your location to be
used and your employer says hey isn't
that so and so's house that was at the
Christmas party last year and they
weren't even involved in the production
they left the house they they received
income legitimate legal income reported
it to the IRS paid taxes and now they're
gonna lose their job there was a guy in
Florida named Tom or Scott Genki he was
a town manager he was employed by the
city and his wife not him but his wife
had made an adult movie and they fired
him not because he did anything unlawful
not that even his wife did anything
unlawful but just the mere fact that his
wife was in the adult film industry
an actress and it made a few movies that
was grounds for terminating him from his
public publicly held position and he
wasn't elected but he was an employee of
a public entity and the government you
know they say that you have First
Amendment protections to freedom of
expression freedom of speech etc here
you have these public institutions that
are that are terminating people for
perfectly lawful off-duty conduct well I
was focusing on that when I was
researching and kind of preparing to
talk to you which is so what we're
talking about lawful activity that's the
primary thing so then what really is it
about the participation in the adult
films that would cause a company to
dismiss someone and we're really talking
about either offence or or or we're
really talking about hang-ups and social
stigmas right because we have eliminated
the possibility that it's an illegal
action and if you think that down those
lines many people would be highly
offended given the negative impact that
the fossil fuels industry is having on
our planet right now and on our society
about somebody working in that field but
we're really talking about the same type
of arbitrary decision right you could be
offended that somebody was working in an
adult film in kind of the same way that
you could be offended that somebody
participated in the fossil fuels
industry which is having such a negative
impact on society and if I think if we
gave that example people would realize
how absurd this is oh absolutely I mean
the idea is is you know think about
somebody who works for you know
anheuser-busch I guess is embed our
right if I'm if I'm the owner of InBev
and I'm creating alcoholic beverages
which some religions like say Mormonism
are have an opposition to drinking
alcohol it's immoral under their tenants
of their law you know here's a guy that
that's creating a product that
contributes to you know kidney disease
or liver disease you know all the
domestic violence that comes from that
duis deaths on the traffic on the
highway nobody has ever died from an
overdose of pornography and morality is
very subjective right like for me I'm an
animal rights person I think that
hunting and killing another animal and
taking away another life is immoral yet
it's lawful and as an employer is a
public
I shouldn't be able to fire someone just
because they're a hunter I mean I live
in the United States where this is
supposed to be a society where we have
the First Amendment not to protect
speech that you enjoy we don't need the
First Amendment to say I love you
we need the First Amendment to say I
hate you and the thing is is even though
you know I may have to tolerate hunters
that that violate my personal morality
but in exchange for my tolerance of
hunting and just sort of abuse to
animals in my view somebody else has to
tolerate you know their personal you
know moral objections to sexuality I
mean if you look at Janet Jackson right
she had the wardrobe malfunction at the
Super Bowl merely just exposed the
breasts there was no sexuality nothing
it was a huge national news story about
where is this country going because we
showed a perfectly natural breast right
and there was a Jimmy Kimmel did a spoof
on that with Al Jazeera and they had all
these people in Iran dancing around in
full burkas and a sleeve falls right or
arm is exposed and everybody freaks out
and el Jazeera like those nuts and the
Americans laugh at that and go wow isn't
that silly that that they have to dress
like that and cover a forearm meanwhile
the Europeans are looking at our Janet
Jackson incident you know whether
Europeans have commercials of naked
women showering topless for a shampoo
commercial and they look at us and think
you know look at those silly Americans
and the other thing interesting thing to
look at is this is the societies that
are more tolerant of sexuality I
actually have the best rights towards
women if you look at countries like the
Netherlands or Western Europe or the
Nordic countries or even Canada they
have some of the best treatment between
men and women yet in most of these
prostitution is legal pornography is
legal etc where you look at societies
where where women women's rights are not
the best access to abortion etc those
have the most constrained because
women's behavior whether that's
Afghanistan Iran Iraq or even here in
the United States you know our our
women's rights here are less than they
are in Canada in Western Europe and you
can see that our level of sort of sexual
tolerance or sexual or even women's
sexual empowerment is directly
correlated with that level of freedom so
the more regards to the employment
though just to get back on that what
we're really dealing with here in the
you
is a situation where most people are
employees at will right so well no
matter what our perception of oh it's
silly to fire someone because they
worked for ambev in bed rather and that
creates so many car accidents or they
worked in porn very few people are in
unions and and most people are just
employees at will
sure now you're talking about a private
public distinction so in in most states
in the u.s. you can fire somebody merely
because you don't like the color of
their shirt you can say you're wearing a
green shirt
you're fired in a match to that is that
an employee can quit for any reason or
for no reason what what I'm trying to do
is to apply this to the to the public
public employers in the sense that to
say if everybody's paying taxes right
the only the only you know beef that an
employer can have is a public employer
is someone who's doing something
unlawful because everything else that's
within the purview of the law should be
acceptable to a public employee since
everyone has to pay taxes if I work for
Burger King you know and they fire me
because I was in the adult film industry
I can retaliate in the sense that I can
stop consuming Burger King products I
can go to McDonald's or Wendy's
however if say a school district or a
city discriminates against you right you
can't stop paying taxes you can't say
you know I don't like the way the school
board is operating let me stop paying
taxes to the schools I'm still mandated
to pay taxes to the schools and the
property values therefore if I'm
mandated to pay taxes and I have no
option regardless of how the school
board is performing then these public
employers should not be permitted to
fire people for the sort of the
subjective you know moral choices that
go against the public employer think of
it like this let's say you're a
principal of a school and you have two
two teachers say one of them you know
got a dog from a dog breeder over the
weekend and you think as an animal
rights person that you know that these
that dog breeders are bad and people
should adopt from shelters if you're
gonna allow say public schools to
arbitrarily fire teachers who had been
in the adult industry even Hooven are
currently in the adult industry there's
no different from that principal saying
you know I've just said I'm gonna fire
this English teacher because she adopted
a dog from the pound and meanwhile I'm
gonna fire this science teacher because
they drink alcohol on the weekends and I
had a son who died in a DUI and I feel
bad about that so they're fired
arbitrarily
that's the issue now there are states
like Colorado North Dakota California
and New York that have state statutes
that protect what they call lawful
off-duty conduct and this also applies
to private employers so in the sense to
my earlier argument that it's an at-will
employment situation that's true but not
when it comes to protected classes like
race of course which engender race etc
and I think that in my view which it
might be a little more progressive is I
think that lawful off-duty conduct or
conduct within the law on your own time
should actually be a protected class
because so many people are adversely
affected by employment decisions as a
result of stuff that has nothing to do
with their job based on the arbitrary
morality of a certain administrator at
the organization we've been speaking
with Dave pounder the book is obscene
thoughts of pornographers perspective on
sex love and dating really great to have
you on very interesting topic here
thanks for having me